[Music]
[Applause]
let me bring in uh peter schrager
he is one of the co-hosts of the emmy
nominated good morning football that
airs monday through friday at 7 00
eastern on nfl network
is that the first nomination for the
show we were nominated once before
and did not win i've been to that thing
in a tuxedo and uh
sat there while wilbon and kornheiser
mailed it in didn't even show up and got
theirs
it's an honor that you guys know quite
well to be nominated to show up and
watch uh two individuals who don't go to
the event get the award for the six
thousandth time so
maybe one day we'll get pti and mclovin
did come on the show and basically
talked about andy dalton and our ratings
went skyrocketed
it was awesome well you can still have
him on
while he still has a job in chicago
because i don't know how long you think
it is before justin fields takes over in
chicago
it's interesting because i think if matt
maggie was about you know saving his
career
or trying to just last as long the move
is you start dalton until like week 10
or 11 fields comes in and then suddenly
has this resurgent second half of the
season well you can't fire naggy now
they just got started but
i go back to 2012 or 2012 yeah when i
was covering the nfl for fox and i
showed up in seattle for training camp
and matt flynn just signed his training
uh his free agent contract for huge
money and everyone was like we love
flynn
um but our third round pick is
outplaying him every single day in
practice and
looks amazing we can't not start this
guy and it was russell wilson
if fields does that in training camp i
don't care what plan nagi has
with mahomes and alex smith in his mind
with dalton
if fields is the better quarterback the
players know and you can't go
into week one and say yeah but we have a
plan no no no no
fields is the guy we'll see him on nbc
with alan chris on the call taking on
the rams week one
um who should have drafted justin uh
justin fields
you know it's funny because i think he
ends up in the right place and he's got
an opportunity to start and he'll be a
hero because of the big ten connection
and chicago's
always had this quarterback need what
was interesting to me was that teams
passed on justin fields like
if he goes on to be great will the
broncos regret taking a corner when they
already have
some great corners at nine overall well
the panthers regret
taking a corner how about the eagles the
eagles had the 10th overall pick and
justin fields is sitting there
do we know if jalen hurts is very good i
don't know if jalen hurts is better than
justin fields and they took a wide
receiver with the first pick when they
traded back so
i find that to be interesting that 8 9
10 and the eagles kind of get a pass
it's like all right well they traded
back and they got a third round pick and
they got devonta smith i think if if
justin field is a great quarterback
it's almost like when when the bears
took trubisky over mahomes
and watson everyone crushes the bears
for it but you also know the 49ers took
solomon thomas over mahomes
and watson as well so if you take a wide
receiver and justin fields on the board
and he goes on to be what everyone hopes
he can be then i think that's a very
interesting decision by philly
what is desean watson's trade value
i don't think it's much right now to be
honest dan i think everyone's waiting to
see what happens here and everyone's in
wait and see mode so
but even a civil lawsuit or lawsuits
that are settled
what's his trade value trade value is
they drafted a quarterback in the third
round and davis mills and they've got
tarad taylor and if he's
cleared of these things or he settles
them and the nfl gives him a suspension
for a few weeks and then he comes back
and they welcome him back on open hearts
and he's willing to play for them he's
the houston texans quarterback
i don't think he has even 80 of the
trade value he had
back in february when these stories
started coming out and
i could tell you that there was a lot of
teams that were thinking okay well let's
at least put desean watson on the board
and say what would it take to get them
and those calls weren't answered by the
texans nick casario the first year gm
was like
he's not on the block we're going to
work this out it's going to be fine and
then this stuff blew up and i don't know
any team who wants to
touch this right now i don't it's civil
non-civil settled not settled
it's not like you can't play quarterback
anymore i just don't think any other
teams
want that on their hands as this is all
happening as you said before the break
why is it that we always hear the
dolphins involved in
you know possible trade talks or getting
a quarterback you know russell wilson
deshaun watson
you know they they've had two of for a
year and not even a full year
like it just seems this this is what i
kept seeing with san francisco with
jimmy garoppolo
he's our guy meanwhile we're
we're trying to get tom brady uh you
know we're trying to trade garoppolo
uh hey anybody else that we can get here
um
it just feels kind of uncertain in miami
with tua
yeah look the niners to finish that
point i mean they did at least
inquire about aaron rodgers the day
before the draft so it's not as if
they they don't have interest to go
beyond jimmy as a veteran or for the
rookie which they drafted the dolphins
are interested because
he went six and three last year and he'd
say well that's great for a rookie but
in the biggest moment in week 16 when
they're playing in las vegas he got ben
she got yanked so when flores comes out
and says i have the full confidence in
him and
he's our guy you almost look at that
with a side eye because in the biggest
moments you didn't you went to ryan
fitzpatrick
they did not draft a quarterback they
had the third overall pick
sorry this microphone all right they the
third
quarterback and they traded back to 12
then up to six and took a wide receiver
to me that's the utmost confidence in
their quarterback
they showed that with their actions and
yet if i was to wake up in august and he
told me oh wait deshawn watson was
traded to the
to the to the to the miami dolphins i
wouldn't be shocked at all
i don't know if you saw this report by
mike florio
he said that he hears aaron rodgers
believes he was promised to trade before
the packers changed their mind
the packers said that unequivocally
false
not only that but the packers weren't
even aware that rogers believed that he
would be traded
it's tough to separate fact from fiction
here of wondering
because i haven't heard aaron rodgers
say anything
but the coverage is bigger than the
story itself it feels like right now
and that for aaron rodgers
wait hold on you got to get your mic uh
see our show was nominated for a sports
emmy that doesn't happen with my
microphone but who takes the hit for
this he's on
our show that should hurt that they
should they should re-vote that's good
morning football equipment
that that's what that is the subterfuge
yeah
no see is he you know what schreiger's
doing he's sabotaging him he's
sabotaging
he's tanking the segment wow how's this
there
are you back now are you happy with what
you did do you know how excited i am to
come into your studio
the one down there in tribeca or the one
in connecticut and i'll sit on your lap
i'll hug you then
i am so ready to be off this zoom i'm
all the people on your your show i'm the
last one i don't know if i
want you sitting on my lap i know get
the traeger grill ready i'll just give
you some food whatever you want um
back to rogers it's become a cottage
industry now of like i played with
rogers at some point in my career let me
and let me
weigh in and tell you that he's going to
be happy um the truth is we've all been
hearing
all off season anyone who is in my role
that he's unhappy so the packers can't
say that they were
blindsided by that but then you get to
the different degrees of it did they
know he wanted to be traded did they
make a promise to be traded
i don't know i don't know that i just do
this that rogers has not refuted any
reports out there
including the jerry krause one including
the jake komarow one
and including the one that he wants
goody to be fired he has not come out
and said anything so
the man who is most silent in this has
been rogers and the silence is deafening
to me it tells me that he's not refuting
any of this
he's going to let it play out he's going
to let everyone talk and say what they
want to say
but all those negative charges and all
those things that were accusations
he hasn't refuted one and said now wait
a second that one's not true
and knowing rogers he watches everything
he hears everything i i think he's aware
of what the conversation is right now
and he's not out there batting his fist
saying now wait a second that was not
right that one wasn't right
to me i know he's unhappy and everyone
just thinks because we're two weeks
removed from the shefter report
that things like you know okay the dust
is settled cooler heads will prevail
i don't know if that's true i think
rogers is still really upset with the
packers
who should trade for him i think denver
should trade for him i think denver
should give the farm for him
they've got a really good young roster
and they've got a first year gm and
if his big first swing is to get aaron
rodgers that's amazing
and i think the other team is i think
the raiders should listen i think the
raiders should really consider it
derek carr has been a good quarterback
in this league but they are opening a
new stadium in vegas
they've got a whole new feel and i feel
like gosh roger's in vegas like the
raiders become the most relevant team in
the league
and i don't know what it would take
draft pick-wise but i i'm of the belief
i look at like what seattle did
with jamal adams and what the rams did
which you and ramsay and now what the
niners did
draft picks to me are they come and go
if you can get aaron rodgers
i would give him whatever they're asking
for yeah but he's not closer to a super
bowl in denver
like if i'm looking at this from aaron
rodgers perspective of
you're not gonna have control over the
roster i don't think you get to pick
if you're the one being so upset under
contract for three years
and you've got this team that's gone
13-3 and you're so unhappy i don't think
you also get to pick where you end up
i don't know because he can just say
look i don't want to go there i'm going
to retire
okay like i would rather retire than
wear another team's jersey i mean i look
at it this way
you know it's he doesn't have a no trade
clause he doesn't have the same like
everyone's like well they wouldn't want
to ruin relations with him on the way
out it's pretty ugly right now
and he's still there and i look at
detroit stafford talked to the lions
they were like we're rebuilding let's
make this work let's make you happy we
don't want to have a calvin johnson
situation
packers aren't looking to rebuild right
now if they had to trade aaron rodgers i
don't think
they'd be letting him dictate where he
goes anybody apoplectic on the tim tebow
situation there on
good morning football no in fact we've
taken the other side of it i think we're
all like
relax everybody he's going to try out
and it's fine but i know it's become a
much bigger debate on other shows and
people are
outraged by it i can't get upset about
it we know what it is
urban knows tebow he's gonna bring him
in he's gonna give his give his guy a
shot and if he makes it good for tim
tebow he earned it i don't know what to
say otherwise i mean it's
i don't cry for the undrafted tight end
and his opportunity being wasted by
tebow tebow deserves a shot if he wants
to play
do you know that the cowboys used to
draft
players in other sports oh yeah the
cowboys
they they drafted carl lewis they
drafted pat riley
i mean imagine if that happened now how
these shows would be up in arms can you
believe they wasted a pick on
a basketball player or a track guy
absolutely and and like spurrier in 2002
when he came to washington didn't just
bring one of his guys
he brought jacquez green he brought
shane matthews he brought danny werfel
like this is nothing new
college coaches like having their
familiar faces in there this is the guy
who's the extension of me
and even if tebow shows up for training
camp or a couple weeks into training
camp and
sets the tone and here's what coach
likes like he made an impact
i know there's greater issues at play
and and people will say well that the
opportunity cost of
tebow taking a roster spot there i mean
someone else who's more worthy didn't
get that opportunity i'm sorry that's
the real world
and unfortunately urban meyer has to
make the decisions he's a private
business in this case and he can put
whoever he wants on his team
i hope you have a great weekend peter oh
my god i got worked up there by tebow
you did it i know i did
i i i i kind of toyed you good luck with
the sports emmy guys
thank you people should win we should
thank you peter
thank you that's peter schrager who i
think tried to sabotage
his segment there nfl network good
morning football